the epicenter right now tom brady new
england patriots and we talked earlier
in the program about the reality based
upon a tom curran item from nbc sports
boston that it's not a done deal yet the
tom brady is leaving the patriots there
was a frenzy that broke out in
indianapolis last week as reporters
tried to get ahead of the story and i
think we all feel there's a collective
benefit to our interests if tom brady
does leave because it will become one of
the biggest stories we've ever seen
especially depending upon where he goes
but chris
it's still not a done deal now let's
assume for these purposes it is a done
deal what do the patriots do
next at quarterback
if and when tom brady is gone that's the
subject of this segment and i'll let you
go first give me a guy or two that that
you think would make sense for bill
belichick josh mcdaniels and company if
tommy leaves well i i mean i i think
right we're like the we've heard the
rumors in conversation i do think the
andy dalton thing's real i do i i
believe that now i will state with this
i start off with this
i do think there is great
uh hope
and potential in that organization i
feel or the feeling for jared sidham
who's there now whether they want to go
and let him ride and die and be the guy
in year two of his career i doubt that
uh but i do think andy dalton would be a
guy that i look at right away that hey
yes he he can run that offense you know
i think andy dalton you know a little
bit like ryan tanner's probably a little
better than we all give him credit for
uh and it just hasn't always been
perfect around him there with the
cincinnati bengals so that would be
option number one and then hey if ryan
if tennessee's gonna mess around with
ryan tannehill and all that i would
fully expect that the new england
patriots get involved in that
conversation you know he fits the mold
too he's a pocket quarterback has the
size they like he can throw the ball and
of course can make some plays with his
legs as well i would think that would be
the next guy they look at if they can't
figure out an andy dalton
trade
and let me just say this about ryan
tannehill if bill belichick makes a play
for ryan tannehill
chances are tannehill is going to be a
star in that offense simple reason they
dealt with them from 2012 through 2018
subject to whatever games he missed due
to injury and just all of the 2017
season but he knows this guy he's come
up with these exactly to try to stop
this guy the same reaction i'll have for
tandy hill is the one i had for stephon
gilmore when they signed gilmore it's
like this guy's gonna be a star in that
defense because they've seen him ten
times over the last five years they know
what they're getting because they've
been his opponent so they may not want
tannehill because of that but if they do
if they do that's the ultimate litmus
test
to say he's going to be great because
they wouldn't want him if they didn't
think he was going to be great based
upon everything they learned while
dealing with him that's right dealing
with them they saw him in the wild card
play-off game this year you know i'm
sure there's people on that staff that
still talk to mike vrabel and he's told
them things that are probably positive
throughout the year about ryan tannehill
so
i'm with you i mean i think that that
makes a lot of sense you know and i
don't know if we get closer here to the
free agent deadline i'm not sure so sure
tannehill's not the first guy they call
and then maybe andy dalton's plan b from
there you know and then hey where do
they go after that i think is the next
question like what if those two options
don't happen what if andy dalton gets
traded to the cincinnati bengals what if
you know the tennessee titans and ryan
tina he'll figure out a long-term
contract here sometime in the next 10
days where do they go from there i think
that's the big question to me and that's
where i don't know and you know i'll
flush it out with you here
well there's one guy who is undefeated
in his career against the new england
patriots now he's only 2-0 but still 2-0
against the patriots in this decade is
pretty impressive and that's cam newton
wouldn't that be something if cam newton
ends up in new england now you'd want to
be damn sure he's healthy
but you're looking for a quarterback
with some mobility and a coaching staff
that would know how to use him the right
way and not unnecessarily expose him to
injury man that is a fascinating concept
i still think the charges make more
sense because they need someone to fill
up that stadium but boy the patriots
could do a lot worse than cam newton and
they've seen some of the best of newton
when they faced him and lost to him
twice yeah they definitely you're right
there's not a lot of quarterbacks you
can sit out there and say i've never
lost the patriots i got a winning record
against tom brady i mean cam newton's on
the short list there you know i feel
like russell wilson i think he's got the
edge on him and i mean we're talking
about maybe that's about it
i guess the thing i look at with new
england you know and cam newton yeah i'm
sure they could be successful yes i just
don't see that being their cup of tea i
don't see them wanting to move to that
type of offense quite yet i think
there's just a little too much
uncertainty uh with the health and then
the contract situation i don't know i
just don't feel like that's something
new england's going to want to deal with
right now
here's the other thing i think we need
to consider because look the patriots
typically in free agency
will sit back and wait for other
developments that are going to be more
expensive to happen right and then they
they they know that they can get a
bargain it starts for week two for them
it could be that even though quarterback
is a critical position that they know
that after that first week when the
music stops there's going to be some
quarterbacks standing around saying what
the hell do i do next and that maybe
that or maybe it's just like the
ricochet from wherever brady goes we
talked about trading for garoppolo
earlier if he goes to san francisco
garoppolo makes a ton of sense to go
back to new england so it's going to be
a fascinating story we'll be back with
more right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports